oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un conte moi quand l'unité ont failli de
gemma lire le grand yaka m'ordonnait des
dragons punis mais je le connais en
amendant je suis désigné pour faire le
ménage avec ses balles et je dois
ramasser poussière et la mettre dans ce
paquet pour la montrer aux grands yada à
ces familles bolou comme probable je
vais commencer par me reposer il faut
toujours se reposer avant de travailler
lui dit qu il fatto pas sur mon corps si
le brouillard n'envoyait y serait pas
contente
un plus petit bâton
on va jouer aux régates
[Musique]
je paie 9 ans avec nos baleines en avant
les petits bateaux et titus je viens
surveiller ton travail j'avance et mon
cas toi c'est une méthode personnelle et
ça al'air abusant de l'essayer montre
qu'à toi tu habites le ballet et l'air
qu'ils déplacent d'avancé les bateaux
officieux passion s'appelle derrière un
bateau est celui qui arrive le premier à
la colonne de fonds a gagné c'était
capable de mosca ne reviennent pas je
lui ai dit va surveiller le travail de
têtu et servir immédiatement
mais je ne reviens pas jusqu'à mosca
mais où était le passé moscou s'est si
bien si il y passait ses mots ce cas et
ramène le tu as compris si il est bien
vase et puis je te donne une minute pour
amener mosca qui ont perdu tant mieux
car c'est mon bâton qui va gagner
constitue g show jeu russell et toi bien
fait non plus 20 noyer le bateau allait
fayette meetic raté tus mon bateau a
rattrapé le tient je dis ceci
qu'est ce que tu fais ici je parie que
c'est le grand yaka qui t'envoient ils
pillaient a ordonné de me ramener ici si
tu n'as pas envie de voir des trn ou
qu'ici pas cherché à bâle et titus va
faire un bateau pour toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et à bâtons pauvreté mathieu est ternie
si on veut faire avancer en faisant de
l'air avec ton ballet qui a trois
bateaux étaient encore plus rigolo je
suis anti rides est capable et ceux ci
qu'ils ne reviennent pas que tout cela
va me chercher mosquée et ceux ci et
puis que ça un site où se situent de
deux autres combattants qui viendrait
avec nous va prendre à bâle et s'est
offert un bateau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
de plus en plus forte la bataille navale
habite là était de nous rattraper il
un émoi nécessaire et me disais tu sais
moi les blagues haca m il m'a marqué et
je vois quelqu'un comme nbc et ils ont
rempli le coup de bâton eason diminué
mais le centre ville ces quelques 1000
coups de bâton j'étais dépassé boca ses
barreaux d'un coach qui me gêne aux
lèvres la regarde mon corps une visite
ou là où la sauve qui peut c'est le
grand yaka par la barbe de mes ancêtres
mais qu'est ce que c'est que sial grande
yaka
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter mes
petits bateaux du patou de mon palais
mais à l'horizon que moi mais
certainement grand yaka tout six bateaux
sont les vôtres
c'est bien c'est bien alors je suis le
grand yaka des petits bateaux voulez
vous jouer avec eux et c'est j'étais
très rapide dans wii a essayé de bien
sérieux site us ils bossent et qui
quitte je te nomme amiral dg veut dire
et un petit bateau le grand gala a
balayé tout emballé et nous trois
un conte moi quand tu étais où pi2g
malien le grand yaka m'ordonnait des
travaux puni je le pouvais en amendant
je suis désigné pour faire le ménage
avec ses balles et je dois ramassèrent
poussière et la mettre dans son baquet
pour la montrer aux grands yade a fait
pas mine gaulle ou comme probable je
vais commencer par me reposer il faut
toujours se reposer avant de travailler
des petits bateaux par son montant si le
brouillard nos voiliers historiques
comptant un plus petit bateau
on m'a joué aux régates
[Musique]
je paie 9 ans avec nos baleines en avant
les petits bateaux et titus je viens
surveiller ton travail j'avance et mon
cas tu vois c'est une méthode
personnelle et ça a l'air à busan et
essayer montre qu'à toi tu as it le
ballet et l'air qu'ils déplacent
d'avancé les bateaux messieurs passion
s'appelle derrière un bateau est celui
qui arrive le premier à la colonne de
fonds a gagné c'était capable de mosca
ne reviennent pas je lui ai dit va
surveiller le travail de têtu et servir
immédiatement
mais je ne reviens pas parce qu'un mosca
mais où était le passé moscou s'est si
bien si il y passait ses mots ce cas et
ramène le tu as compris qu'ils étaient
bien vase et iggy je te donne une minute
pour amener mosca intervenants monde car
c'est mon bâton qui va gagner constitue
g show jeu russell et toi bien fait non
plus 20 noyer le bateau allait fayette
meetic raté tus mon bateau rattraper le
train je me dis ceci
qu'est ce que tu fais ici je parie que
c'est le grand yaka qui t'envoient ils
pillaient a ordonné de me ramener ici si
tu n'as pas envie de voir des tenues ici
pas cherché à bâle et titus va faire un
bateau pour toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ea bateau porte et mathieu est ternie
tout ne fait avancer en faisant de l'air
avec ton ballet qui a trois bateaux
étaient encore plus rigolo je suis un
homme tue reid est capable et ceux ci
qui ne viennent pas que le talent cela
allait me chercher mosquée et ceux ci et
plus vite que ça a c'est tout ce que tu
viendrais avec nous pas prendre un
ballet s'est offert un bateau
à peine plus en plus fort c'est la
bataille navale indique cela est
peut-être nous rattraper
un émoi nécessaire et me disais tu sais
moi les blagues aka et bien marquer et
on voit qu est-ce qui commande ici et
ils ont rempli le coup de bâton eason
10000 20000 centre ville ces quelques
1000 coups de bâton j'étais dépassé boko
ses barreaux d'un coach qui me gêne au
collège la garosse une visite ou là où
la sauve qui peut c'est le grand yaka
par la barbe de mes ancêtres mais qu'est
ce que c'est que sial grande yaka
j'ai le plaisir de vous présenter mes
petits bateaux du patou de mon palais
mais à l'horizon que moi mais
certainement grand yaka tout six bateaux
sont les vôtres
c'est bien c'est bien alors je suis le
grand yaka des petits bateaux voulez
vous jouer avec eux les cgt trapping oui
hein et ça y est c'est bien ça y est tu
ce ils bossent et qui quitte je te nomme
amiral dg veut dire et un petit bateau
le grand gala a balayé tout emballé et
après c'est notre travail
[Applaudissements]
racontez moi donc il était mon fils je
maquille mon programme feder était la
danse au fait tu m'avais vu d'entrée
[Applaudissements]
tu es là bien sûr aussi que je sois
gillet pas tout encore dix voitures
d'entrer avec moi d'un petit orifice
profitons-en pendant que le grand yaka
prend sa douche au pas ça fait plaisir
de voir un peu la lumière
alors on dans will orchestre que leurs
coffres
mais les musiciens tu fait ainsi sa
musique aux la musique la musique tu
crois que tu est indispensable que les
questions pendantes peut-être sans
musique chez les lions mais pas chez des
souris
nous sommes des artistes nous avons tout
va devoir apprendre à dompter sa musique
me fait mal lâche me
[Musique]
n'abuse adoucit les bols à vous voilà
call mauel enfin pour les musiciens dans
ma poche trois exactement ça être un
bras gist hors jeu là rapporte un de ma
tournée triomphale un aux états unis
en 10 de son enfant
[Musique]
au revoir vous me donner le mal de mer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrêtez arrêtez méhari type push les
musiciens club dedans à côte
[Musique]
c'est une plaisanterie dès le creuset
qu'un autre du la mucite et veut voir
les musiciens à bahreïn où dès qu'il y
en a pas voilà allez mon cabas dans les
commissions vite pérennise rentrer dans
la peau titre legrand langue à 90 en dhr
fait pas du 6 au titre legrand trouve là
ils te feras tenter un coup de bateaux
de pêche
vous en tant qu bien appartient garde le
lot brabus temps et arrête la musique
titus coup sûr les musiciens il y en a
pas grand rue à cas mais je te la
musique écoute ma foie gras encore me
manquent pas mais moi jen terme pour ce
cas est-ce que tu aimes tu as des
musiques toi ça dépend encore yaka mais
je l'entends - c'est une musique de mes
oreilles jeu l'inter et on vous connaît
sa gran via quatre cantons de bobonne
moment s'est tarie bhl du bout de nous
mêmes ces grands hommes qui disent non
non grand yaka mettez ces boules de
coton dans mon oreille et vous
l'entendre à tous les boutons moment
auquel je suis des cours donnés mosca et
c'est superbe et je n'entends plus rien
vient d'entrer dans la liste legrand
gamme entendent plusieurs vivent la
musique
et après après près d'une onde d'espoir
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raconte-moi d'enquêté au pays de gennady
il fallait d'israël au grand bien quand
tu fais tu ne te prête de sutil
tu vas voir c'est cela oui mais ici il y
as et évocation de ce type y écoutez moi
c'est comme ricky j'ai fini mon autre
témoin oui si tu es toi tu vas aller
avec cela et tais toi je parle tu vas
aller avec ceux-ci prévenir mais le
coeur qui viennent me dit faire y
compris aller dans ce sens est parti en
garde des mc mario balotelli ramener la
droite au visage a compris
oui alors j'avance le pied droit 1 je
saute sur le pied gauche de peu se trace
racle ou l'autre des cours attitude
démontre moi ton pas encore vu jouer ici
alors poussez vous je vais dans cette
lancée m en longueur où vous croient
comme dr howse et traductions legrois ya
qu'un le demandent les spa mais ouistiti
[Musique]
c'est maladroit punira pas mon meilleur
jeu manier chez moi je juste bon tels
que nouveau teint qui vont s'étendre
d'un le voyage chap tame regardait ce
toujours là on est à quelques tables et
voilà
et oui président haïtien fait autre
chose
act up bin voila j'ai déjà vu ça c'est
démodé un seul bulletin blanc voilà
c'est déjà dit c'est qu'elle commence à
intriguer
du haut de ses 7 séries c'est stupide
ben est jouée à grand complet j'ai déjà
vu c'est très facile ça où l'on s'en va
on va le voir pour melchior tu me déçois
d'une sixième vers montauban quelque
chose de nouveau de bézieux je veux que
tu me fasses sauter de rire et vous
oh oh oh oh moi moi il ne
je suis écroulé je suis renversé but et
je suis parti plus généralement un
courant conventionnel grand yaka et ne
ne suffisait c'est très bien celui ci
était très réussi oui très nouveau après
c'est une autre histoire
titus raconte moi quand météo pi2g la
lire
et bien voilà c'est fait tous les
métiers j'ai même été porteur d'eau
dematic grands lacs à mbankomo quel
corps fait quelques faits ces malades
qui comprend bien pâle poche et j'ai
besoin d'un peu d'air froid fut tu veux
rendre un petit service titus 300 civils
et achètent ercis le grand yaka a besoin
de moins pour sa séance de gymnastique
je veux tu me remplacer avec plaisir
d'abord lors de nos valeurs parfait
c'est parfait et bien va vite au gymnase
le grand yaka y est déjà maman le
plaisir dans un trampoline au granada
grand yaka non voilà leur remplacement
score pour la gymnastique 1er janvier
c'est pour vos mosquées ne tient pas
debout
alors qui voici leur jeunesse de mon ami
glisse où l'on entre dans la vie mon
petit qui fait maigrir puis voyons
premièrement se posait sur la bascule
comme bien aujourd'hui 201 qu'il vaut
mieux rire 26 titus au moins 42 et des
miettes
je suis le plus gros et c'est moi non
plus puisque je suis le grand yaka
ensuite dans un moment taper dans le
ballon
vannes faute d'autrui sans rajouter près
et bien à l'oral ou titus ta poubelle le
ballon une fois ce respirer un deux
trois caps et plus forts se tissent plus
vite et j'avais espéré c'est bien ça me
fait du bien de se voir taper si fort et
si cette saison moi avoue kron gacko moi
je n'ai qu'à me suis trop fatigué titus
tu es là pour faire 6 exercice complexe
on comprend pourquoi montesquivais c'est
la corvette dans une optique va me voilà
frère alors je continue ma gym 2 6 3
immeubles 40 attractions débat ou pas
les seuls et titus c'est excellent
libéral et qu'il faut que je trouve un
moyen de mon époque de grâce à perdre 28
même si des deux pieds c'est une très
bonne exercice unique et 39 faut que je
trouve une idée pour nous sortir de
l'homme vous vous pas finir en soutenant
lors ge peu d'imagés multiples
le quatrième n'a soulevé les ultimes
j'aime beaucoup cet exercice a laissé
les monstres l'on doit faire
il faut soulever le tir et le tenir un
brin tendu au dessus de la t6 très
efficaces font maigrir c'est très
efficace
ça y est les midis vous allez voir
dessous lève je tiens au dessus de ma
tête et violente ou est l'alter gros
temporaire ne peut survivre magnifique
cette magnifique vous sans réponse est
très dangereux pour vous grand yaka de
dire tout - et pourquoi pas ce concept
énorme ne doit pas retomber sur nos
pieds et crack
vous aurez pieds plats comme oscar qui
s'était juré il faut protéger mes pieds
j'ai pensé grand yaka vous allez vous
mettre ici est monté ce sont deux
tabourets et comprend titus titus je le
vire tudieu tenez bon tenez vous bien
voilà mon fils on serait ce qu'au regard
de dieu je suis pas du tout le feriez
bien fait et très bien les ballons
voilà il était temps qu'on arrête ces
exercices les désarmer grille de 4 kg ce
grand gars me répondre comme un morceau
de bord à la toile et après après c'est
une autre histoire
[Musique]
un tournoi compliqué au prix de genavir
tu qu'on a permis la fruits je l'aimais
bien typés pour elle demande pourrait
couper en quatre rémy finit dorine qui
est la brünnhilde two door et bim qui
est là haut au brennus
tu es sorti seul de ce bien que cet
homme prudent c'est le treuil à cames
voix il même à jara pourquoi et tortueux
rechercher un miroir et une amende aux
indes miroir à le rendre dans potiche
je ne peux pas vivre sans miroir il faut
que je me vois que la tête aux pieds
pour m'habiller
je rentrerai damas potiche quand j'en
aurai un bon c'est un ultimatum que
laura ton miroir parole de lyon bla un
miroir bros est bien venue des touristes
faut qu'ils ont trouvé un héros ou à
maître malka bongo bouton debias très
heureux de la 3g un besoin de mes
services avaient voit un miroir ladha au
miroir c'est à dire le glass ronde car l
ovale eux alors foule toi-même ayant un
peu de désordre
josep enfin le ménage depuis quelques
jours et un fouillis là dedans
voilà on le sent tout petit miroir je ne
peux tout de même prévoir les galerie
des glaces aux bêtes touche
exclusivement notre mal quoi consommer
on ne conviendra pas car c'est nous
mêmes notre mal que de bien vouloir most
1 il a peut être ce que tu cherches une
bonne idée mais où est il demande qu à
cette sortie
y'a qu'à vous est superbe et ouais c'est
magnifique mais aller bosser mois encore
dans le doubs c'est ça une petite
poussière
voilà après jean si le grand yaka veut
choisir le collier d'aujourd'hui
celui-ci donc horrible n'obligeait les
déjà porté à voter mais c'est le mode
cas alors peut-être que celui-ci
abominable neuneu il est trop petit mais
je veux des pires plus grosse que toi
tais toi ne fait pas de bruit
le grand yaka est très occupé de moi mon
score yala miroir quand on voudrait
emporté l'étude ipass par titus chez le
miroir du grand yaka au magal mon beau
mais tu es fou ouvrions tu ne l'aura
jamais jusqu'à un mois
alors viens m'aider voilà vingt grandes
ya un moment tu es mon plan je veux
mettre celui-ci les deux mois mosca et
puis c'est qui ce point faire craquer il
faut tirer doucement si tu casses et ce
collier tu auras des coups de bâton tu
as un thermostat et où il n'y a qu'un
certainement graille a qu'un et il est
accroché un autre dépêche toi mosca mais
je vais me regarder dans ma mémoire
i wanna voilà que jaka je le tiens être
splendide c'est que je suis ici pour moi
jusqu'à ce qu'un oui oui il ya quinze
jours on va chier c'est incroyable je
suis sûr que c'est une astuce de titus
n'est ce pas parce qu'à ce miroir doit
être regarde c'est une injure pour le
gaillac à aux grenats cas c'est affreux
j'ai nommé belloy le double oui oui oui
il n'ya qu'un je l'enlève je l'enlève
ticket lille et miroirs ben monsieur
samoa le grand yaka monde qui si le plus
beau tu as gagné titus tuer leur adresse
tus un miroir du grand yaka tous trois
ans qu'on demande car il n'est tombé
rémy saha h ce titus il réussit à me
donner foi dans le tout et après après
c'est une autre histoire raconte moi
quand tu étais au pays de gêne à dire
par mettons me souvenir hulot mais comme
je n'oublierai jamais et celui de l'est
tél
[Musique]
enfin petit moment de repos bazzoli bien
mérité nous avons à nous laisser
tranquilles si l'on réussit un beau
bateau dans le donnerait à bérénice et
le faisait souvent de tout mettre sur
orbite à tuer là je suis souci world
compris toi tu as encore des ennuis
ils sont là ils vous suivent qui m'ont
vu c'est bien fait pour toi tu n'avais
pas raté ses trois ans titus cash mois
ici il arrive qu'on soit derrière moi
vite ici 6 1 6 1
ce qui on en trouve un moment bâtonnets
petit frère qui ne parlent pas tous à la
fois et laissez-moi traduire
or vous faire c'est bérénice c'est ça
qui est bien moins on sait où élèves
vous ne pouvez pas l'attraper
ici elle est où là on consommait d'une
colonne et pour la prendre il faut
monter sur une échelle
vous avez raison mais petit frère à les
buts a fait une telle qu il y fit vite
dernis il faut gagner tapoter sans
perdre une minute
voyons que qobuz de moi tu parlais de ma
petit ah oui j'avais tout cas c'est trop
tard ils reviennent vite pas derrière
voilà les spl non non la pause et par
ici c'est la bac pour la mettre ici ici
ici fils il y fit
mettez là debout ou tournerait plus
facilement que le cube de bourdy vous
continuez vous allez vous conseille les
banques bon on a déjà un progrès à
présent avec kiki bérénice je vais les
éloigner dit si on prend la direction
des opérations
virez moi à mon cas mon combat ma
question
on s'arrête ici allons bon
nankin va vite rattraper cela irait on
était tous les deux bravo vous avez
trouvé la mort hier après dans devez
vous dire où et bénéficie des nids et là
haut pour l'attraper il faut monter à
les pelles colloque plus courageux n'ont
bousculé pas y en aura pour tout le
monde
cela soutient les selles toi ce petit
monde d'accord kiki qui voulaient les 31
au sommet de la colonne mais ils n'y
arriveront jamais comment manque de
barras est inédit vous allez monter en
avion ça vous plaît qui sont belles et
elles ont dessus de votre tête
ceux ci avancent d'un pas c'est bien
cela recule d'un pas c'est en fait
attention aux mouvements d'ensemble a
baissé les bras
la voilà lancée tout c'est réussi 6 6 1
l'avion décolle dans le cinq minutes
data de vos ceintures de sécurité comme
sa bourgade tranquille et moi au fus
s'ils me cherchais toujours notons qu'un
pas ces deux nigauds se croient en avion
et il a dans le de gaulle av
et après après c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la conduite et aux pays du gema dire
tout ça commente le lion le plus patient
de la terre et serviable comment faut
pas me prendre pour un mouton bons
ballons dit puisqu'il faut balayer
balayons plus chétifs tu m'amènes avec
toi ce que je bois la fête du four et
eti m'aider alors pour commencer ne
jette plus de papier par terre
tu es tu m'avais zimmer je m'en fais
et voilà le travail tout le monde est
n'importe quoi par terre c'était tout ce
ballet alors si tu veux tu te puce comme
d'habitude
as tu as de la chance tu n'as jamais
trop chaud toit ni son ni fois son nom
c'est moi qui nettoie on le dirait pas
ce pari est dégoûtant cole mentalités
commencent quand on se prend pour le
grand ouaga
bonjour mon garçon heureux de te voir je
vais te montre à mon dernier tour de
prestidigitation permettez qu'on aura
que les miettes et en gros ça sans
importance l'esl est aubin et pousse toi
attention quelle bio cabas voilà c'est
raté
tout est un petit morceau 90 ans mais
cet automne à celui de tous les jours on
commence à en dire ça un artiste que
benoît titus plus andré gras en gras ou
pas tellement qu'ils nettoient alors et
pas regarder moment fort des fêtes
d'artistes haut rang qui se gêne pas
voilà c'est fini tout est propre aux
noms trop fort pour un aspirateur
fétiche 1 et par les parties ni les
moussu plaidé soyez juste conviendra
plus grande épuisette des sols c'est
betty toi et travaille au lieu d'être
puisque je vous croyez que je m'amuse
sommes alors ça va changer
je vais m'amuser et une fois que je
travaille alors les gars à mon cheval
tracts propre cote roulant raconté
agréable de titus qu'est ce que tu fais
et travailleront yaka de travail que
cela dit et de travailler dans la voix
et tu peux vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
et veiller comme certains sites us un
plaisir incroyable qu'un dommage que
vous n'ayez pas ce plaisir grand yaka et
éthiques
je veux la guerre mais le péché que tu
as ces sites c'est la fois les niches au
mollet le second travaillez vous voulez
mon balai
1 voici le voilà c'est le ballet du
ballet qui veut mon balai comme le plus
adroit que la prime on pas je vais jouer
benedetti tu veux travailler comme titus
je veux le même plaisir que titus lui
même fortement goliath avancer mon balai
il est à vous voyez comme il valait bien
un moins espérer un mois du bonus les
ventes de montres ou tu fais titus en
force et le ballet oui ce n'est bien le
manque les élus d'abord assez périlleux
c'est merveilleux
je travaille je travaille sur ce site
agréable
ne restez pas sur place promenez vous
dans votre palais un peu mal pour le
ballet et la prochaine fois qu'il me
dira de travail et me fais ce qu'il me
reste à faire
et après après est une autre histoire
raconte moi quand tu étais un pays que
j'aime à dire on paye nos âmes à dire on
n'est jamais malades alors n'y a pas
d'eau médecin n'est un goût comme s'ils
ont dans ce palais je n'ai pas entendu
crier le grand yaka de la zone et son
neveu parson tout évident de silencieux
les schémas tâche est dure shacham ont
quasiment tout sauf à l'urgence nous
voir ce que vous savez bien nous irons
les chercher chez pierre charon ce cas
explique mois restant sur un bon je vais
me renseigner pour faire du bien malade
voilà voilà voilà grand yaka buvait ce
jus de pastèque mon nom je n'aime pas
une petite bière
je veux de la tisane et demi qu cool
l'afrique rayak à une tisane de miku
cool je reviens grand yaka
[Musique]
[Rires]
je suis content parce que je joue à être
malade
le muscat motricité mais on me dira ce
grand gars il fait le malade pour se
faire dorloter et là on va voir toujours
j'ai chez moi tâches y ait urgence est
mon cas c'est tout le grand barca n'est
pas malade il s'amuse à ton père fou
rire avec ton plateau à la main
titus tricheurs de ce que tu dis mais je
croyais arrêt tu peux me croire vollard
en bus comme auto voir ce grand yaka
mériterait
dans nos bons à l'enfant lé dakor moscou
et est toujours une petite chante i q
mon dieu le cosim alors mosca mathieu
demy concoules est grand car j'ai trouvé
mieux qu'une tisane je vous jamais d'un
betchat l'illustrent titus kahn qui y
est allé de ses énormes et je ne veux
pas de médecins eux n'a alors à l'ombre
en kayak en eau vive agité pas voyons
cette maladie je sens dans la fièvre là
dedans en jean pelletier avec cet
appareil dont un vin d'honneur pour le
gros sauvegarde aucunement du rgo bon
genevois la fièvre sérieux qu'ils font
soigner et narry comment vous écoutez
monsieur lemay de chez vous transpirez
je n'ai pas l'esprit
apprenez que l'illustrent petite cantine
au centre on peut quand même une favela
piège rayons au présent le système
nerveux
le dj sinon à décaler je vous ferais
bien mal en point
voilà si tu aimes bien ne refuse jamais
monsieur 2006 je vous assure voyons le
poumon à présent le nom offrira pas des
pros spiro et louis n'en reprend pas
transpiré pour vous
et les communs comme un jeu le
trouvez-vous moment pour moi entre amour
et mon ex tram ou ses gammes le pur
moment extrêmement gras puisque je suis
malade extrêmement mal à vous guérir et
si vous suivez mes instructions il n'y a
qu'un grand mère
ed dans ma vie je n'ai pas sommeil et
droits de l'homme me baigne alors je te
c'est tout c'est surtout le sommeil et
la santé et voilà mon temps quel petit é
ça va faire trois jours deux vaincus moi
je vais danser avec des émissions qu'on
le grand yalgado les souris dansent à la
et après au fait c'est notre histoire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
raconte moi quand tu étais au pays de
l'uma dire quand il avait préféré
mon style est très malheureux et à vous
il dresse aujourd'hui heureusement que
nos grands canaux ne veut pas travailler
ainsi tu seras qu'elle celle vers je
suis je suis accablé je suis fondu un
peu d'air frais me ferait du bien on
encore la donne est dans ton mari le
rappeur mais je ne peux pas je dois
porter l'on prêche du craag aka venue un
peu par an je te prête mon éventail de
parts d'ombré le gambiaka et toi dans
ton esprit des rappeurs vraiment rond
qui tue mais chitti d'espérer et et
madame 2,3 fin de décrocher un précieux
mais je ne les ai pas sûr moins
abondantes à rien tu me le gaulois tout
à l'heure quand tu feras apprécié
d'apprendre et bien un problème tu auras
tu crois vraiment en attendant les trois
plans allons porter l'ombre el hogra pas
mon grand lapin la partie ouest france
tout le monde cela est obligé de céder
le tout le monde dort ici ne vous
dérangez pas pour moi ce qu'on voulait
faire de cette encombré l'ombre allons
te fait en grand nombre élevé la ville
est cet homme nombreux comme ça quand
ils te réveilleras il me dérangera pas
lumignons claude douheret au mieux des
bêtes venues la voir si le nombre et le
mode ia grave
bon on peut remplir ombrelle terminée et
à présent devraient de la mémé croire en
un mot ce qu'a fait de bien gagner de
graffan fait une bonne affaire
et là mon frère mon gars tu es toujours
à ces petites us je viens surfer mais
croissant ils n'ont même pas tu peux la
sourde oreille
la famille d'un croit femme tu sais tu
m'as pas ce qui manque donc pas dis le
moi je voudrais bien vous conduit qu'à
droit et vous me laporte
attention un tel droit au moment où
donner de la tête aux pieds
malheureuse pas moins eu beau faire de
la thune fout de ton est trop grand
froid en pleine opération
heureusement commencent à arriver à
temps les témoins ventes au dessous de
zéro
quand tu me donnes sûr avec toute la
glace maintenant il faut que je fasse
fondre cette glace fond
un beau feu de bois et tout va fondre
comme une pipette
voilà la potel allumée faisait pas
d'allumettes pour cela lui même sur moi
au haut auquel spectacle rafraîchissant
le grâce aux pingouins
je paye coulter nitoo fait pas vous
allez le cas c'est peut-être là l'une
est dans votre camp schwab et dans les
chapelles à l'ovation mois c'est trop
dangereux allons rendre était libre il
ya du bac
aucune arme à feu sur moi on ne joue pas
avec ces choses-là
comment faire pour aller pour demoscope
où il faudra bien tout seul pourquoi
veux-tu le faire fondre un petit
chaudron
il me dois de croître alors tu n'as qu'à
attendre le dégel
un peu de patience qui tous en attendant
le grand absent de la grille fermée
trois banques
et après après est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]
un conte noir quand tu étais au pays du
g ma vie écoute héros gaffeur qui
t'avait mauvais rémy s'est mis en tête
de faire du tricot
depuis ce matin et pouces et 240
colonnes j'en ai afin de respirer de la
poussière à des habitations à pour cette
poussée à bout par khartoum et j'ai
encore 300 colonna a alloué au besoin
avec pour tout ça continue on à tomber
en poussière
piquée au but servent à un père joue au
petit tu as ruiné un bond à ce jour
toutefois une grosse écharpe de laine
autour du cou
je vais chercher ce qu'ils font non
robert du jeu dépendant de l'étape
c'est là bon coeur aide-moi net c'était
chaud de l'emploi et ensuite tu te crées
4 est une belle écharpe
on vous vend revers hazare a mis en
place comme tu dis ça parce que tu
pourras je te connais tu it is not moi
t'expliquer ne bouge pas sinon tu vas
tout embrouiller aura duré longtemps
certains joueurs purs le temps de faire
la pilote qui tissent lève les bras
faibli bras tu vas tout en mêlée obiang
ouvre mon gloss ou même j'ai toujours la
même chose
le crin kaka veut voir qui touche et
quiétude est introuvable
si vous regardiez veridis tu vas branché
nier tu as dit de regarder autour de
vous autour de moi autour de moi mais je
ne vois que toi p rédige je gardais mien
fait un autre tour d'horizon mais je ne
vois que les colonnes qui tournoient et
le tournis qui s'empare de moi
je vais essayer j'ai la tête qui tourne
petit tour de qui tourne même à plottes
arrête-toi mosca qu'anti pourtant laine
souvent nous le croyant tarde à venir à
lille vient tout à fait tiquer masculin
est alors allé chez le gagnant que tout
cela eh bien je vais les chercher ses
motifs et ou de ce palais chez moi
zobo incite au musée et sa tournée où
s'était joué pour moi ça et sur mosca me
l'avait caché ils nous tuent tous ces
mots ce cas moi je les casser ça donne
ça y est reparti et il repart à cet
habitat
il faut comme oscars vient de voir ses
joues émerveillé est-ce que c'est
périlleux mosca whittier en paroisse
tout tourne autour
tu vas te tirer de là aller marche
arrière et en avant pour la balle saint
lambert
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jaime jara becker la voiture attitude
j'étais sur le point de perdre haleine
mon dieu si le grand yaka le creux
diakham appel excuse-moi titus et bercy
bercy bercy un mot fort longtemps sans
fin ou qui va m'aider à me sortir de là
mais voilà si cela commence aussi font
un vrai sens et fonde non et après après
c'est une autre histoire raconte moi qui
étais au pays de gêne à dire à vous
devez récolter plus de 3000 ou de bateau
va comment commander échappé à ça
commence à devenir confortable en temps
je me sens et moi je suis c'est bien
pourvu qu'au fond d'eux est bien mais
qui touche b mais que fais tu deviens
toi heureusement ce cas on ne pose pas
ses pieds sur la table il ne s'agit pas
de tes pieds allant de quoi faire dit il
mais tu croyais à cavaillon tu n'as pas
les pieds sur la terre tu choix attend
pas vous l'avez oublié je te préviens il
est de très mauvaise humeur il capable
de voler près ces menteurs sauvage
phagocyte ipouck un petit reflet du
venin sur boston du coup de bâton pour
les jeux en bois qu'à aller mosca un
registre titus où étais-tu là bas l'abba
xiam a péri sur le coup de patin mosca
un registre ce fait si tu étais assis ça
m'a permis d'y entrer bientôt en écoute
de button sait sur quoi ça ma permission
d'un coup de bâton à les 1 211 cas voilà
je vois la carotte c'est ap et après
après faut voir ailleurs sans ma
permission roues et 50 coups de batterie
après
d'autre part à autre par j'ai ma
permission
60 coup de bâton à l'evo ce qu'a fait la
soustraction héros rend là encore la
vision wac commun qu'est ce que si 80
coups de bâton pour contradictions de
chaque coup de bâton pour inscription 3
salles qutb atom pour additionner mostar
c'est là je verrai dans l'opération et
s'est fait doucement doucement voyons
alors eu nous disons que sans ses trois
chats et voici l'édition je sache
alors alors alors alors alors alors
alors menacé de placer la machine à
bulles qui est alors le bien sûr mais je
le placer je veux percer des coups de
messages en a avec notre tradition ne
peux m'en foutais de la réparation
titus et la permission de la permission
de m'en doutais et le piston des sources
tracteur qui bloque la dir nord ce qui
fait que le temps d'une rose art est
coincé à et sherry barrât
voilà pour question fini est là et on
dit gestion beaucoup de bateaux mais
alors que faire très tard je vais faire
l'addition moi-même tutu schefer les
éditions l'addition c'est ma spécialité
à et de prêter ses 242 pour 40 40 - 142
route nous et 0 c'est bien pas c'est pas
moi c'est bien pas 40 au moins 40 égale
verront hors jeu sans doute cherche sans
doute à l'ordre car j'ai vu le résultat
et si vous voulez vérifier grand yaka
jouer chez de le total nomme 40 - 40 jeu
égal 0-0 et ses machines et qui dit
s'amuser à evry la machine c'est zéro et
c'est l'opération zéro
même si une petite brise hommes
je suis très satisfait de ma machine
titus tu auras géraud coups de bâton 0
points prend les raccords et après après
c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]
raconte-moi coq météo pays devine à dire
j'ai appris beaucoup de fonds entre
autres celles ci un peu d'astuce
on place beaucoup de force 19h03
d'accord reine de coeur h2k et tout mon
coeur je vais te laisser seul car on a
tout à coup que tout doit gagner on est
bien content a enfin notre monde arabe
en bois ne l'est pas mais dit il non non
je viens seulement peut emprunter un
livre pour faire la lecture aux grands
yaka un livre pour le grand yaka sur toi
à mon score ma bibliothèque et à sa
disposition
sites intéressants au moins passionnant
bien côté des sports de lyon fut devrait
avec des images et bien merci titus
merci toujours à conserver ce monstre à
bonne nouvelle baby nouvelle à
tranquille pour un grand moment
mosca mais oui les mosca mosca oui tu es
mosca je veux que mosca monitise
histoire vous aider voilà voilà grande
yaka
j'ai trouvé un livre passionnant alors
mes toiles à et commence la lecture
première histoire le lion et la
grenouille une grenouille célibataires
se plaignait de sa solitude un vieux
lion philosophe je suis seul
que faire et le lion lui donne h conseil
qu haché et bulles type liés
à busan le manga très bien il dort déjà
alors partons sont fiers de free et
romanska avait continué notre histoire
voilà voilà la croix qu'un deuxième
histoire le lion et la torture oui en
effet alors une porte
pressé de se rendre à la ville se
lamenter sur sa lenteur à lyon généreux
qui passait par là vie pleurer la tortue
et lui dit les nuits du montet dont sur
moto vous voyagerez à dos de lyon des
quoi je dois tout atouts des lions
atteint tout mais ce magnifique tu as
dit ado de liens je vis c'est bien ça
messieurs atouts des lions à remo ce cas
allez monsieur sy titus immédiatement si
court ya qu un 1/2 de mêlée se
contenterait d'un coup de pic attend
encore gagné ah voilà notre monde un
certain manque à ma bd blian tête étape
habile provisions non non non tu sais
pas de livres chez toi que je viens
chercher hors jours du grand yaka au lit
je parle un français gilles babinet
excusons a beurré me revient
titi approche du sel et plus je suis
très content and soon hwi après très
satisfait le testeur que vous plaire un
grand gars bon alors l institut ce jeu
le faire comme la tortue je veux voyager
à tous de lyon avait atteint agrado de
gollion mais tu es mon lien alors tu
veux ma porte et surtout des grands lacs
avons fait mais je me serais plus facile
mr mongrain encore vous allez vous
attirer des ennuis avec la société
protectrice des animaux société
protectrice des animaux gm supprime
aller je veux voyager à deux des lions
blancs
hu qu'est ce que j'ai nous avons pu par
toulouse fait pas attention ça va
commencer parce que je suis et mon réel
pic du tissu et qu'est ce que tu as tous
craqué comme ça et en voyant son sort
n'est plus sérieux chérien émérite sur
tout le corps et âme au début une
toiture député alé lô et l'autre est que
puisqu'elles ne joue pas je vais tirer
parti plus mal et les jeunes au talent
mais si vous voulez bien monter sur mon
grand gars quand même les choses
devraient aller à l'étranger les petits
plus seule et même entité pu sillonner
les matins mais tu me rassurez vous y en
ait pas de pull beige avons combattu et
après après c'est une autre histoire
un couteau - cocu été au pays des jeunes
a dit talent sang froid il m'a fallu
j'avais tous les jours un problème à
résoudre
je me demande où ils sont tous français
y a personne dans ce palais aujourd'hui
ton frère tu vois l'attitude enfin de
voir la montat
moi j'ai vu personne de plus ce matin
beiba le rugby chez que tout le monde
est mobilisé pour préparer le pique
nique au promu renouvelle et a prévenu
les bien sûr mais oui le grand yaka on
met tout le monde et tu es convaincu au
même homme pleinement à bord mauvaises
herbes
alors qu'un flic mieux perçu des limites
et rien n'est fait titus et j'étais même
un pique nique est un grand plaisir pour
moi grand yaka et alors mosca point sur
les préparatifs et il a faim se croient
ils savent que je m'en occupe l éthique
je suis débordée titus je suis déporté
le feu tu allais voir si belcher à
préparer les sandwichs et ouais bon
alors ensuite cuire à surveiller ceci et
cela
ils font cuire le rôti et ensuite tu
viendras me retrouver derrière le trône
du grand yaka
pourvu que tout soit prêt à passer
d'habitude
encore un petit effort et baby show et
terminerait alors nationale car cet
endroit où santé des bons jeux dhabi
suis arrivé trop tard
ils sont finis par me retard mais on les
avait voulu tuer naturel vous dans mon
estomac voyons ouah vous l'avez comme la
dame en berne tous tous sans exception
selon les ordres de bosca il m'a dit
fait descendre riche et terminale a
rapidement
tu te rends chose titus de 3,250
sandwich à malin en cinq minutes pour
n'en n'était pas maître malka jaune f1
et j'en suis fier
à présent je vais faire une petite
promenade digestive le grand gars
catastrophe et le rôti pour vous que
leurs auteurs
et si pareil quand c'est le rôti du
grand hyatt à te trouves qu'il en rêve
ici ici ou là même en v1 disparaît paix
sinon je vous mets à la brosse à dents
sans doute pas de rôti il faut que vous
prévienne monga voiture il ne faut rien
oublier une couverture des couches 1
alors alors alors titus tout est permis
d'y aller ça pour faire pour pas tout
est terminé fini à feu mais oui voilà ce
que j'ai pu sauver mais j'vais mais chez
toi un monstre mon bien-aimé pingouins
assiette walaa mots tu fais une mauvaise
nouvelle annoncée avant lui persuadé j
minutes
il est prévu un pique nique wascat mais
séduit bons outils
wasquehal je suis désolé c'est une
catastrophe
la route de baffin un nom dans ce cas
maintenant elle est mon père je vais à
renwez panneaux bouffe pas ils vont
pique nique n'est pas prêt il peut plus
belliqueux jeu mais monsieur lui je me
rocci grands lacs à toute épreuve voici
votre pique nique commun mais c'est une
hausse
oui grand gars un autre superbe données
lance total le repas complet ils nous
avaient conomique avec un autre comme
tommy si vous en avez pour x 30 ou 40
pique nique chez nous avait fait le
pique nique à la mode grand yaka titus
apportez moi c'est tous avaient tendance
comme ça vous avez le plus beau pique
nique du monde et je suis content je
continue quand je fais une petite icône
à moi de moi et moi
rue lallemand pas mauvais et après après
c'est une autre histoire
[Applaudissements]